and as always it's not just about the
destination it's also about the journey
lee macmillan has died according to a
post on her instagram page
the social media star died by suicide
following a battle with depression
she was 28. on friday a woman was struck
and killed by a train
near santa barbara and the county
sheriff's office identified lee as the
woman on monday
lee was previously reported missing and
the police feared she may have been
suicidal on tuesday a heartbreaking post
on lee's instagram page
confirmed she had taken her own life
a message that read quote she was the
brightest light
a magnetic force of nature and was loved
by so
so many lee was a well-known instagram
influencer and vlogger
she gained a massive following as she
documented her trips around the world
we did it along with ex-boyfriend max
lee's videos of her exotic travels
led to nearly a half a million
subscribers to their youtube channel
max and lee it is inspiring
uplifting jaw dropping all the same time
lee also got very personal about her
struggles with depression and anxiety
and she had become a vocal mental health
advocate i've done a lot of reflection
on
how i first started feeling depressed
because i'm not a person who's grown up
feeling chloronically depressed
in this instagram post from december lee
opened up about having suicidal thoughts
i did get to a point where i felt
suicidal and it wasn't that i wanted to
die it was just that i didn't want to
feel
that pain anymore and that living was
harder than not being awake
i felt like i was no addition to anybody
else in the room and
i truly felt like my presence on this
planet didn't matter
lee later thanked her fans for their
support and wrote quote
this community is so incredibly unique
and i am so grateful to share this space
with all of you